البابا فرنسيس هو في اليوم الثالث من
زيارته للبحرين التي استمرت أربعة أيام ، حيث أمضى
اليومين الأولين في لقاء معظمه مع
قادة المسلمين هنا ، لكن السبت
كان للكاثوليك وخرجوا
بالآلاف إلى قداس في الهواء الطلق في
استاد البحرين الوطني حوالي 30  000 شخص
من الحضور وفقًا لمنظمين محليين
الآن الكاثوليك في هذا البلد
هم بشكل أساسي عمال أجانب من الهند
من الفلبين من سريلانكا
وبعضهم جاء يوم السبت من
المملكة العربية السعودية المجاورة يقودون
الطريق السريع البالغ طوله 16 ميلًا والذي يربط بين
البلدين بسبب بالطبع في السعودية
الجزيرة العربية لا توجد
كنائس كاثوليكية ولا يتمتع الكاثوليك بحرية
العبادة ، لذا ربما تكون هناك فرصة واحدة في العمر
للكاثوليك في هذه المنطقة
للاحتفال بالقداس مع البابا فرنسيس
أول بابا يزور البحرين في وقت لاحق
من اليوم الذي التقى فيه فرانسيس بالشباب.
البحرين الكاثوليك والمسلمين على حد سواء
وتشجيعهم في أحلامهم
للمستقبل خاصة من أجل
التعايش السلمي البابا فرنسيس را  ps up
رحلته يوم الاحد عائدا الى روما
بعد ظهر الاحد
ديليا غالاغر سي ان ان المنامة البحرين